take a look at steven's numbers on the
year this one uh relief appearance was
a disaster i guess you didn't get
anybody out there it was a it was a
a really a total mess
and a twisting fly out to right polanco
will give ground
and frazier able to track that down
lebron wins the battle thanks to frazier
that was a pretty nice play polanco
running in on you so you got to be a
little fearless right here
i think that that's why you saw frazier
reach as far as he could to make that
catch he didn't want to get like right
underneath it aaron cevalle will be the
nissan starting pitcher for the tribe
tonight he's coming off a win against
the tigers where he went six innings now
the wind and the two two
and it's swung on smashed on the ground
to first
right at santana he'll make the play
unassisted and aaron savali cruises
through the first
see if he can't get santana
one and two
ground ball shortstop newman on to first
and well done one two three
go the indians after one and a half
here's gregory polanco he is really
struggling and he hits the first pitch
right on the ground right at the
shortstop frankie lindor in the shift on
the right side and savali gets through
it in a hurry and we're now to the third
inning here's roberto perez the catcher
he saw it but he swung and missed the
off speed pitch to perez for the third
strikeout from brawl
this ball bounced toward the shortstop
and that's a 6-3 put out and
what a different pitcher since the first
no score in this one third inning two
down and the 2-2 delivery now target
inside corner and savali's pitch is
swung on in a jam job he hit a spot and
a weak fly to center and the shields
will make the catch somali's made 36
pitches
in three innings
the indians shortstop francisco lindor
he struck out looking in the first ball
bounced to third through the second for
one to first and around the horn double
play started by jose osuna cleans that
up five four three two outs
two balls two strikes the pitch from
brault hit in the air toward right
polanco comes in several steps after
going back and now makes the catch and
we played three and a half cleveland
nothing pittsburgh nothing now the
right-hander into the wind here's his
2-2
swing and a miss strike three got him
with the heart stuff two down in the
inning
strikeout number three for savali
breaking ball tap to the shortstop
lindor nice play in the shift and just
like that another quick inning for
savali
and now first and third nobody out for
domingo santana and the indians are in
business here in the top of the fifth
inning hard shot back to brawl gonna be
a double play oh a bullet
my goodness what a nice little break
that is
right in that club i mean he wasn't even
out of the box and there's two outs
[Laughter]
one ball one strike pitch and there's a
ground ball to the right side and
frazier is up with it and he throws on
to first for the out and what a job by
stephen bralt
what a performance
so a two out base runner on just the
second hit allowed by savali
here's the 1-0 swung on a slow chopper
first base side of the mound savali is
on it sign retired all right two on two
out
big pitch right here from novitas never
oscars
grill
deep right field and she is gone a home
run for carlos santana his second three
run homer in his many nights
that 3-2 pitch ended up in the cheap
seats
and the indians lead it three to nothing
santana comes up big and he's going to
hit the three-run homer from the left
side of the plate get him going boys get
him going
here it is so aaron zavali's got an
opportunity now he can go out there and
see what he can do and have a quick
inning and put his zero out and the
pitch swung on grounded up the middle
lindor with a flip to second hernandez
for one turns the double play
nicely done as lindor ranging up the
middle to his left and now the bases are
empty two down strike three call that
comeback fastball got the outside corner
savali's fifth strikeout the way
savali's been pitching i mean he has
just been fun to watch here is the 01
pitch
swing and another weak fly ball to
center coming in as to shields he'll
make the catch and aaron savali is just
slicing and dicing up these pirates if
santana's patient this could be four or
nothing in a moment
santana bangs it fair ball down the left
field line that's going to get home jose
ramirez front neal's going to score as
well on his heels here comes tyler
naquin it's a three-run double for
domingo santana and a six-nothing
indians lead
savali is able to keep his edge because
folks he's been as good
as you can possibly be without being
perfect a swing and a miss high fastball
ghetto sooner
six strikeouts for somali and it's swung
on bounced on the right side savali has
a one two three inning he's now pitched
a career best eight innings tonight
folks he's going to get a complete game
tonight trying to go the distance we'll
see if he can finish this off
in the air center field
delino is back on the track
and makes the catch
aaron cevalle has his first career
complete game